it's time for seen and unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that W return to Fox News
contributor Raymond Royo all right
Raymond as I mentioned in the angle
Biden made a sudden stop to the Auto
Workers picket line in
Michigan yeah this was a little more
like a refueling stop on the way to the
West Coast but the president needed a
script Laura
desperately stick with it if you deserve
the significant raise you need and other
benefits let's get it back who we lost
okay we it's about time never step up
for
us get back what we lost what did they
lose they're asking for a 4 day work
week Laura and a 40% raise at a time
when Biden is uh dropping new climate
regulations on these auto manufacturers
and offshoring all of the battery
components to China and the Far East
none of this makes sense now Ford wants
to bring in a Chinese battery
manufacturing company into the United
States so I I think these workers aren't
going to have to worry about it much
longer if CH if if these globalists have
their way China will just dominate the
whole EV market and then it'll be the
end of the story
bye-bye like this is easy Biden spent
exactly 12 minutes with those striking
workers which is one more minute than
the number of times Commander Biden has
bitten Secret Service agents they're now
up to 11 attacks the Biden dog thinks
the Secret Service are his personal chew
toys at this point now uh I mean this is
outrageous what we're see let me let me
correct you Raymond no no Commander he
seems to be getting along with the
Secret Service now like we set up I
think we set up our own Commander Cam
and it looks like an agent is playing
with commander in the yard right
[Applause]
now it seems to be working out really
well Laura the training is really
catching up look the the White House in
all seriousness claims that the dog is
under stress because he's in the white
house but there's a whole team of
working dogs at the White House they
don't bite anybody well the one thing
you're supposed to do is make sure that
the Secret Service are okay because
they're the guys who are protecting the
president so the guys are in gals who
are protecting the president are now
under attack so maybe it's stressed out
about interest rates the inflation you
know don't get as many Milk Bones The
Milk Bones you know they the shrinkage
shrink flation The Milk Bones are
getting smaller too so that's hard on
dogs well you know what when the pet is
a problem they always say look at the
owner but so long as we're discussing
White House attack dogs kamla Harris met
with children today at a YMCA event
unlike Biden She's Always unburdened by
what is and what has been on
repeat it takes a
commitment it requires optimism
it requires the ability to see what can
be unburdened by what is and what has
been in your lifetime you have only
known a climate
crisis extreme weather
occurrences in your lifetime you
witnessed a
pandemic where you lost
substantial days months of school I a
question is this supposed to be
uplifting this is the most depressing
speech by well you basically don't know
it's all the climate is burning up and
you you were masks triple mask for two
years and you know we're she talks about
optimism and then she she plants drops
all the downers on the kid the
environment's are going to kill you and
you lost years of schooling due to the
pandemic have a good day kids Raymond I
think Commander is it's it's a cry for
help I was thinking about Commander it's
a cry from help help help Commander get
get rescued from the White House we need
to help Commander I suggest he go to
Raymond's house CU Raymond loves biting
dogs easy easy long as I get a choke
chain and a mask on that thing don't
care hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else